THE TERRITORIES TOLD FOX NEWS,
QUOTE, THEY WERE NOT BEING
JUDICIOUS ABOUT WHAT THEY TOOK.
LARA TRUMP, AS PROMISED, A
MEMBER OF THE TRUMP FAMILY,
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO DONALD
TRUMP JOINS US NOW.
LARA, THANK YOU FOR BEING ON THE
PROGRAM WITH US TONIGHT.
I'LL START WITH THIS.
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT?
HOW IS HE DOING?
WHAT IS THE ATTITUDE OF THE
FAMILY?
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO MY
FATHER-IN-LAW.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, YOU KNOW,
HE'S AS SHOCKED AS ANYBODY.
I THINK FOR SOMEONE -- AND
ANYONE QUITE FRANKLY -- WHO
LOVES THIS COUNTRY, AND BELIEVES
IN AMERICA, THIS SHOULD SHAKE
YOU TO YOUR CORE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TODAY.
THIS IS A VERY CLEAR DEMARCATION
IN THE HISTORY OF AMERICA.
NEVER BEFORE, AS MANY OF OR
GUESTS HAVE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT, WILL, HAVE WE SEEN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN,
WHERE AN UNANNOUNCED RAID BY THE
FBI IS CONDUCTED ON A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IF THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THINK ABOUT
THEY COULD DO TO YOU, TO ANYBODY
IN AMERICA.
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
THESE DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN QUESTION HAVE BEEN --
EVERYBODY'S COOPERATING,
EVERYBODY FROM MY
FATHER-IN-LAW'S TEAM -- HAS BEEN
COOPERATING WITH THE FBI WITH
ANY AUTHORITY THAT ASKS FOR
ANYTHING UP UNTIL NOW.
THERE WAS NO NEED TO MAKE SUCH A
BIG SCENE, TO DO SOMETHING THIS
INSANE, QUITE FRANKLY, TO A
FORMER PRESIDENT.
I THINK EVERYBODY CLEARLY KNOWS
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE, WILL.
THIS IS ABOUT WEAPONIZING THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS IT HAS BEEN
SO MANY TIMES IN THE PAST
AGAINST SOMEBODY WHO YOU
POLITICALLY DO NOT LIKE.
THEY DETEST DONALD TRUMP, NOT
JUST ON THE DEMOCRATS' SIDE, BUT
THE GENERAL ESTABLISHMENT,
BECAUSE HE'S NOT ONE OF THEM,
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T PLAY THEIR
GAME.
THEY'RE TERRIFIED HE'LL ANNOUNCE
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024, AND THIS IS A CONVENIENT
WAY TO THROW A LITTLE MORE MUD
ON DONALD TRUMP AS THOUGH THEY
HAVEN'T ALREADY DONE ENOUGH.
THIS IS THE SAME AGENCY, DON'T
FORGET, THE FBI, WHO, YOU KNOW,
WHO HAD FALSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
GET PFIZER WARRANTS TO CONDUCT
THIS ENTIRE SHAM RUSSIA HOAX
THAT THE COUNTRY HAD TO DEAL
WITH FOR TWO YEARS, MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND OUR TIME
WE'LL NEVER GET BACK TO FIND
WHAT?
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO SHOVE
JANUARY 6th DOWN EVERYBODY'S
THROAT.
THAT HASN'T WORKED.
WILL THEY'RE HEADING INTO A
MIDTERM, HEADING INTO A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION SEASON
COMING UP, WHERE THEY KNOW THEY
HAVE NO HOPE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE.
THEY HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE TO
SHOW THEY'VE DONE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU TRY TO TAKE OUT A GUY WHO
HASN'T EVEN ANNOUNCED HE'S
RUNNING YET, BUT THEY'RE
TERRIFIED OF HIM ON THE
DEMOCRATS' SIDE FOR SURE, AND
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, IN THE
GENERAL ESTABLISHMENT.
>> Will: LARA, YOU'VE SPOKEN TO
YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW.
THEREFORE YOU HAVE THE MOST
IMMEDIATE INFORMATION OF ANYBODY
WE'VE SPOKEN TO TONIGHT.
DOES HE KNOW, DO YOU KNOW, WHY
HIS HOME WAS RAIDED?
>> HE BELIEVES IT'S THE
DOCUMENTS IN QUESTION, THAT, YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY HAS BEEN REALLY
UPSET ABOUT FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
LOOK, MY FATHER-IN-LAW, AS
ANYBODY KNOWS, WHO'S BEEN AROUND
HIM A LOT, LOVES TO SAVE THINGS
LIKE NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS,
MAGAZINE CLIPPINGS, PHOTOGRAPHS,
DOCUMENTS THAT HE HAD EVERY
AUTHORITY, WILL, TO TAKE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, HE'S BEEN
COOPERATING EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY WITH THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE QUESTIONED ANY OF THIS.
I KNOW PEOPLE HAVE BROUGHT IT UP
BEFORE, BUT, YOU KNOW, LOOK AT
HILLARY CLINTON, THE 33,000
EMAILS SHE DELETES THAT ARE
COMPLETELY GONE AND NOBODY BATS
AN EYELASH ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP TAKES DOCUMENTS
THAT HE HAD EVERY RIGHT TO TAKE,
THAT EVERY PRESIDENT DOES,
DIDN'T TOOK ANTIQUES LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON TOOK OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND PAINTINGS
APPARENTLY, BUT THAT'S WHAT HE
BELIEVES, AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK IS AT THE BOTTOM OF ALL OF
THIS, AND THE REASON THEY RAIDED
MAR-A-LAGO QUITE